tu m'entends
ça me tue en sécurité maintenant ou
crois-tu être à l'heure actuelle dans le
labyrinthe
il paraît qu'il ya un profilers avec
elle maintenant profilers ils essaient
d'entrer dans sa tête
maintenant on n'a plus besoin de toi
[Musique]
bien soir tu étais dans le marais du à
vue la jeune fille a été arrêtée et a
appelé les secours la fille n'était pas
seul j'ai raison tu appelles samantha on
m'a dit tu as été kidnappés il y à gaza
mon expérience m'a appris qu'il ne
fallait négliger aucune piste des lapins
le moment est sans doute venu de vous
présenter un nid
il faut qu'on sache de quoi tu te
souviens à ce jour et il faut que j'y
arrive avant lui pourquoi
[Musique]
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là je me
trompe
[Musique]
il n'est pas d'or il habite dans ton
esprit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]